Welcome to an all-new... Sorry, Sean, I just felt like... No, I just feel like you're taking yourself way too seriously. It's not like... You have to do that. It's not the first time ever, but I just thought like, wouldn't that be great if our podcast started like, welcome to an all-new... No? Does that sound... Sure. Heavy-handed? Sure.
欢迎来到全新的……抱歉，肖恩，我只是觉得……不，我只是觉得你把自己看得太严重了。又不是说……你非得这么做不可。这倒不是头一遭，但我只是在想，如果我们播客的开场是“欢迎来到全新的……”这不是很好吗？不？听起来……当然。太生硬了吗？当然。
Okay, can I... Do you mind if I... It's just... Why don't you try something more upbeat because you're always so serious anyway. I want to do a... I want to be like, you know, SmartLess is a podcast that Sean, Hayes, Jason Bateman and I do where we each bring on a guest and the other two don't know who it is and then, you know, fun ensues and blah, blah, blah, blah. That's it. That's all you have to say. I could do that.
好吧，我可以……你介不介意我……只是……你为什么不尝试更有活力一点的东西，反正你总是这么严肃。我想做个……我想像是，你知道的，SmartLess 是一个播客，由肖恩、海斯、杰森·贝特曼和我共同主持，我们每个人都会请一位嘉宾，另外两个人都不知道他是谁，然后，你知道的，就会发生很多趣事，诸如此类，巴拉巴拉。就是这样。你只要说这些就行了。我能做到。
Or I could do... Welcome to an all-new episode of... We got it. SmartLess. Smart. SmartLess. SmartLess. So when I was 21, I was in a gas station and a guy comes up and I'm not making this up. The guy comes up and he says...
或者我可以……欢迎收听全新一期的……我们懂了。SmartLess。Smart。SmartLess。SmartLess。所以当我21岁的时候，我在一个加油站，然后有个家伙走过来，我可没瞎编。那家伙走过来对我说……
By the way, it should be... I want to interrupt, but I do want to say, usually when people say, I'm not making this up. I swear to God. This is true. It means that they're making this up. No, I'm not making it up because this is how stupid I was. 20 years old guy comes up and he says, hey, you want some speakers? And I'm like, what kind of speakers?
顺便说一句，应该……我想打断一下，但我确实想说，通常当人们说“我可没瞎编。我向上帝发誓。这是真的”时，这意味着他们就是在瞎编。不，我可没瞎编，因为当时我就是这么蠢。一个20多岁的小伙子走过来对我说：“嘿，你要买音响吗？”我说：“什么音响？”
And I'm not kidding. They're in the back of the van. Wait, wait, wait. I'm sorry. Interrupt again. This time to say, and the guy said, and he held up the work order and he's like, we were supposed to deliver them to the person they want. Is that... Is that what happened?
而且我真的没开玩笑。它们就在面包车的后备箱里。等等，等等，等等。对不起。再次打断。这次是为了说，然后那家伙说，他还举起了工作单，说什么我们本来应该把它们送到某某人那里，对方却不想要了。是这样吗？……是这么回事吗？
No, that's not what happened. The guy says, here, come look at them. I was a little apprehensive, but it was only like a couple of cars away. So go and look in the back and then they're huge, right? These huge speakers. And he's like, they're only 200 bucks. And that was tons of money, but I was like, God, these brand new speakers for 200 bucks. I should just do it.
不，不是这样的。那家伙说：“来，过来看看。”我当时有点忐忑，但离这也就几辆车远。于是我过去看了看后备箱，然后它们好大，对吧？这些巨大的音响。然后他说：“只要200块钱。”那可是一大笔钱，但我想，天哪，全新的音响只要200块。我直接买下得了。
And so I go, would you take a check? I don't have that cash. He goes, sure. So we're on the check. I took these two huge speakers in my car. I get home and my brother's like, what are you fucking moron? And I go, why? What?
于是我说：“你们收支票吗？我没有那么多现金。”他答道：“当然收。”于是我们就写了支票。我把这两个巨大的音响搬进车里。我回到家，我哥就说：“你他妈是不是白痴？”我问：“为什么？怎么了？”
And he goes, out of the back of a van, like this is the point when I learned that this is like not for real. And I was like, well, I wrote him a check. He goes, we'll cancel it. And I canceled the check through the bank and I got to keep the speakers. And were they real speakers? They were completely makeshift plywood speakers and they worked, but they were like, you know, tiny, you know, $2 speakers.
他说：“从面包车后备箱买的，这就是我意识到这根本不是正经买卖的时候。”我说：“可我已经开给他一张支票了。”他说：“那就挂失。”于是我通过银行挂失了支票，而音响最后归我了。那些真的是音响吗？它们完全是临时拼凑的胶合板音响，而且还能用，但它们就像那种，你知道的，微型、你知道的2美元音响。
But that used to be a scam. Guys would drive around the city of New York and you'd be in the village and they'd walk in and they'd go, hey, man, do you know where, you know, West Orders Street is? And you're like, you're on it. And they're like, oh, no way. We're trying to, we had these speakers. They're supposed to deliver them, but they didn't want them. And he like holds out the work order and he opens the back of the van because he's huge.
但这以前是个骗局。有些家伙会开车在纽约城里转悠，你在村里走着，他们会走过来问：“嘿，老兄，你知道西奥德斯街在哪儿吗？”你就会回答：“你现在就在这儿啊。”然后他们会说：“哦，不会吧。我们正打算……我们有这些音响。本该送货的，但人家不要了。”然后他晃了晃工作单，打开面包车的后备箱，因为音响很大。
You know, I mean, I don't know if you want, I mean, I guess I could give you for a hundred bucks. You're like, what, a hundred bucks? Are you telling the exact same story I just told her? Yeah, basically, just better. Like imagine. He's punching it up. Like more fun.
你知道的，我是说，我不知道你是不是想要，我是说，我想我能一百块钱卖给你。你就会想：“什么，一百块？”你是在讲我刚刚讲过的那个故事吗？对啊，基本上是一样的，只是讲得更好听。想象一下。他在润色。变得更有趣。
So it's like auditions go, same dialogue, different dude. Sure. Yeah. Like less like sitting in a therapist's office and more like just having fun, you know. So our guests today are surprise guests. I don't even know how to introduce them because A, he's super funny, but B, he has been part of creating or has created some of the greatest things, movies and TV shows that certainly that I've ever loved and that you have too.
所以就像试镜一样，同样的台词，不同的人。当然。对。就像少去了一趟治疗师的诊所，而更像是单纯的找乐子，你知道的。所以我们今天的嘉宾是神秘嘉宾。我甚至不知道该怎么介绍他们，因为首先，他超级搞笑；其次，他参与创作或创造了一些最伟大的事物、电影和电视节目，至少是我这辈子最爱、你也一定爱过的作品。
And Norman Lear. It's not Norman Lear. So now you got him feeling bad and I can't wait for him to lay into you for that. But he's, he's our Norman Lear. Think about it that way. He's a super, super funny guy. I first got to meet him years ago and he was working with my ex at the time and it was really exciting for me to, to hang out with him and got to know him a little bit over
还有诺曼·雷尔。这不是诺曼·雷尔。所以现在你让他觉得不好意思了，我等不及看他为此好好数落你一番了。不过他，他是我们的诺曼·雷尔。换个角度想。他是个超级、超级搞笑的家伙。我第一次见他是多年前了，他当时和我前任在一起工作，能和他一起消磨时光让我感到非常兴奋，这些年来我也逐渐了解了他，
the years and he has just created, I don't know. It's like, you could just look down his, his resume and pick out what are the things that you like that he produced? Do you like him producing the highest grossing sort of R rated female driven comedy and bridesmaids? Do you, do you like Anchorman? Do you like Larry Sander show that he wrote and produced after a year? Judd Apatow. Do you like, do you like Judd Apatow because he's here right now, Judd?
他创作了，怎么说呢。这就好比，你只要顺着他的履历看下去，挑出那些你喜欢的作品——是他制作了票房最高的 R 级女性主导喜剧《伴娘》吗？你喜欢《王牌播音员》吗？你喜欢他担任编剧和制片人、播出一年的《拉里·桑德斯秀》吗？贾德·阿帕图。你喜欢贾德·阿帕图吗，因为他现在就在这儿，贾德？
Good Lord. He's doing some light reading. He's reading Mary, Mary Trump's book. Hello Judd. That was a, that was a long wait. I read 30 pages of Mary Trump's book. We apologize. But it was worth it.
天哪。他在看一些轻松的读物。他在读玛丽·特朗普的书。你好，贾德。那可真是……等了好久。我读了玛丽·特朗普书里的30页。我们向你道歉。但这是值得的。
You think that was a long time. You could probably watch the movie based on Mary Trump's book during one of Jason's questions because he's not known for his brevity. But it just made me think like, what is going to happen? What is going to happen with the theater experience? Yeah. Or Sean and Jason, are I going to be able to get back to the movie theaters to watch one of your funny movies again?
你觉得那算等得久？在杰森提问的间隙，你大概都能把根据玛丽·特朗普的书改编的电影给看完了，因为他可不是以简练著称的。但这也让我不禁思考，接下来会发生什么？电影院的未来会怎样？对啊。肖恩和杰森，我还能去电影院看你们的搞笑电影吗？
Desperately, please. Yes. Yeah. Is that happening? I think we all don't want to get sick. So we don't go to the movie theaters and then one day someone will say, it's good now. And then everyone will go to the movie theaters. I mean, Russell Crowe had a movie this weekend, which I don't think I'm out of line saying
太渴望了，拜托了。好啊。对。这会发生吗？我想我们大家都不想生病。所以我们才不去电影院，然后总有一天会有人说，现在安全了。接着大家就会蜂拥去电影院。我是说，罗素·克劳这个周末有一部电影上映，我觉得我说它可能是部烂片应该不算出格吧，
is probably a terrible movie and it made $4 million, right? Now a terrible Russell Crowe movie, not in a pandemic, might have made $8 million, right? Like a really bad, you know, not delivering on your revenge, rage, action movie. No, I could be wrong and maybe it's fantastic. Nobody's going to the theaters right now. So that's $4 million that they've squeezed out of nothing in six months for now. I think you're right, Judd. Like six months from now, once somebody goes, you know, blows the whistle all clear, it's
它拿下了400万美元票房，对吧？现在，一部糟糕的罗素·克劳电影，如果不是在疫情期间，也许能拿800万美元票房，对吧？就像那种真的很烂的、没能兑现复仇狂怒动作片承诺的电影。不，我也可能是错的，也许它棒极了。现在没人去电影院。所以这400万美元是他们在这六个月里从无到有硬挤出来的。我觉得你是对的，贾德。就像从现在算起六个月后，一旦有人吹哨宣布一切警报解除，
not like we all of a sudden we've like changed who we are as people. I would also let you guys know that pre-pandemic walk hard made $3.9 million opening weekend. No way. So anyway, you just have to understand. Is that true? That is true. It's like an American classic. That's crazy.
并不是说我们作为人的本质突然就改变了。我也想告诉你们，在疫情之前，《永不止步》首周末票房为390万美元。不会吧。所以不管怎样，你们得明白。是真的吗？千真万确。这就像是一部美国经典电影。太疯狂了。
Judd, how important is box office to you? I mean, Staten Island was awesome. That was, I think, that was just a streaming release, right, because it was right in the teeth of the pandemic. That was video on demand. Yeah. And you got a great response for that. But you have no idea, you know, how like the component of a box office success.
贾德，票房对你来说有多重要？我的意思是，《史泰登岛国王》棒极了。那部，我想，那只是一部流媒体发行电影吧，因为当时正处在疫情最严峻的时期。那是点播视频。对。你因此收获了极好的反响。但你完全无法预料，你知道的，票房成功这一要素到底有多重要。
There's no metrics. Yeah. How important is that to you? It's obviously important for the people that are writing the checks. Is it nice to just make the movie, get it out there and hope the people that are interested in seeing it can find it? Well, for me, I make most of my money on my lip balm. Yeah.
没有具体的衡量标准。对。这对你来说有多重要？对于那些掏钱投资的人来说，这显然很重要。把电影拍出来，让它跟观众见面，并希望有兴趣看的人能找到它，这种感觉难道不也挺好吗？好吧，对我来说，我大部分的收入其实来自于我的润唇膏。对。
And that's where the real cash comes in. It's on Backorder. Root beer. He has a lock on root beer lip balm, not a lot of people know that. I remember my daughter was home one night and she's like, the Jenners are putting out a lip balm. There's only 20,000 of them and they're going to release them at one in the morning and I have to stay up and I'm like, I think there's more.
这才是真正的现金来源。目前缺货中。根汁汽水味。他在根汁汽水味润唇膏领域可是拥有绝对垄断权的，很多人都不知道这一点。我记得我女儿有天晚上在家，她说：“詹娜家族要出一款润唇膏。总共只有两万支，他们打算在凌晨一点发布，我得熬夜守着。”我说：“我觉得还有更多。”
I think that you'll be able to get it in a later date. That's so funny. I mean, for me, I felt like I wanted King of Staten Island to come out because I thought, oh, this is about firemen and nurses and sudden loss and it felt like it related to what we were going through in some way. And luckily I'm in a position where I can roll the dice and hope that that makes sense. I certainly was happy that people got to see it. And the alternative would have been to say, why don't you wait a year to put it out and
“我觉得你以后还能买到。”太搞笑了。我的意思是，对我来说，我当时觉得我想让《史泰登岛国王》上映，是因为我觉得，哦，这是关于消防员、护士和突如其来的失去，它在某种程度上与我们正在经历的事情产生了共鸣。幸运的是，我处于这样一个位置，我可以去冒险，并希望这一切是有意义的。我当然很高兴人们能看到它。如果不这么做，另一个选择就是说：“你为什么不把电影压一年再上映呢？”
just as somebody who wants to get it out of my system, I also felt like it would be weird to have something like that sitting on the shelf for a year that might make people happy in some way. To hold back your joy machines, I know you're all suffering, but I'd like to wait a year to max out my profits. Like it really felt like a terrible choice. But the success was predicated on its reception and on the merits and the sort of validation of box office receipts is eliminated from this equation.
作为一个想把作品从脑子里掏出来的人，我也觉得把这样一部可能在某种程度上给人们带来快乐的作品放在架子上压一年会很奇怪。为了把你的快乐制造机藏起来——我知道你们都在受苦，但我宁愿等上一年来把我的利润最大化。这感觉真是一个糟糕的选择。但它的成功本该取决于观众的口碑、自身的优点，而从这个方程式中剔除了票房收入的验证。
And so your work is just left to be judged for what it is. There's no other sort of nuanced thing in there or some hurricane going up the East Coast that screws everything up for your box office. Like, do you like that that part of it is taken out if you just do a streaming play? Well, it wasn't like a Netflix type of release. There was a gross, you know, people rented it. And so there was a moment of like, I wonder if anyone will pay the money to watch it right now.
所以你的作品只需由它本身的质量来评判。里面没有其他那些微妙的干扰因素，也没有什么沿着东海岸北上的飓风把你的票房搅得一团糟。嘿，如果直接走流媒体发行，把那部分因素拿掉，你喜欢这样吗？好吧，它可不像 Netflix 那种类型的发行。它是有总票房的，你知道的，人们付费租看了。所以当时有过这样一个时刻，我在想，不知道现在会不会有人花钱看这部电影。
I mean, we did have some of that stress, but it's a lower budget in movie. It's not the new Chris Nolan movie. So I feel the bar doesn't isn't that high. I can't wait for that Chris Nolan movie. It looks so good. It's coming out last year. I'm so excited. And I can't wait.
我是说，我们确实承受了那种压力，但这是一部预算较低的电影。它可不是克里斯·诺兰的新片。所以我觉得标准没那么高。我等不及看那部克里斯·诺兰的电影了。看起来太棒了。它去年就该上映了。我太兴奋了。我等不及了。
I can't wait. I've watched it in three of my other lives, but what has ever been more confident that their movie kicks ass than Christopher Nolan, right? I mean, everything that he's doing is just saying like, I got the motherfucking goods people. No, and he's got like, he's got like that for all his movies. He's very confident. I don't know the guy at all.
我等不及了。我在我其他的三段人生里已经看过它了，不过，还有什么比克里斯·诺兰更有自信觉得自己的电影牛逼轰轰的呢，对吧？我是说，他做的每一件事都在表明：老子手里攥着绝对的硬货，各位。没错，而且他的每一部电影都这样。他超级自信。我根本不认识这家伙。
And he makes great movies. And it's always that like, yeah, you guys have great technology, but if you really want to watch my movie, you have to watch it on a 70 million. Like you cannot watch it when they're like, okay, Jesus, man, let me just watch the movie. Like, no, you're going to watch it like this. You're going to be knee deep and muck and like, Jesus, to watch it. But he is. He does have the goods.
而且他拍的电影都很棒。总是给人这种感觉，没错，你们的技术很牛，但如果你们真的想看我的电影，你们必须在70毫米胶片银幕上观看。就像你不能在……当他们说：“好吧，老天爷，求你了，就让我看电影吧。”就像：“不，你得这么看。你得深陷泥潭里看。”老天，看个电影至于吗。不过他确实有两下子。
Judd, do you have any desire to play in that sort of that scope and scale or are you happy with the character driven stuff that you do so well? And well, this is how I do action. Okay. There's a sequence in the King of Staten Island where a Pete Davidson is in a car and he's driving with his eyes closed. And it's, you know, showing you that he's somewhat suicidal as a character. And then there's a car accident and it's very complicated.
贾德，你有没有兴趣涉足那种宏大视野和规模的作品，还是说你对你那么擅长的角色驱动类作品就很满意了？好吧，这就是我拍动作戏的方式。好吧。《史泰登岛国王》里有一个桥段，皮特·戴维森坐在车里，闭着眼睛开车。这表明，作为一个角色，他多少有点自杀倾向。然后发生了一场车祸，非常复杂。
While we were shooting it, I was in the follow van watching the Fedward Nadal Wimbledon final. And let me say, I don't think I missed the point all day. You know, I've got Bob Ellswith, the guy who shot there will be blood. So I'm not really like going, Bob, I think you got it wrong here. You know, you did Mission Impossible. So I'm always proud when they come out. Well, you know, scenes with any type of action. But I remembered like, you know, one of my friends was doing this, you know, this movie
我们在拍摄时，我正坐在追踪车里看费德勒对纳达尔的温网决赛。而且我要说的是，我觉得我一整天都没错过关键点。你知道的，我找了鲍勃·埃尔斯沃斯，就是拍过《血色将至》的摄影师。所以我并不是那种会说：“鲍勃，我觉得你这里拍错了”的人。你知道的，你拍过《碟中谍》。所以每当他们推出任何带有动作场面的作品时，我总是感到很骄傲。不过我记得，你知道的，我的一个朋友在拍这部电影，
with tons of CGI shots and he's just like, I'm just in a dark room with a laser pointer for six straight months, looking for weird mistakes and CGI spots. And I don't know if I have that in me. I assume at some point I will have to do one of these. Like it'll just, just because. You've been offered one. Let me be honest with you. I've been offered nothing my whole career.
里面有大量的 CGI 镜头，他当时就说：“我连续六个月只能待在一个黑屋子里，手里拿着激光笔，寻找奇怪的失误和 CGI 瑕疵。”我不知道我能不能受得了这个。我想我总有一天也得拍一部这种电影。就像……纯粹因为没办法。你收到过这样的邀约。老实说吧。我整个职业生涯都没收到过这种邀约。
You know, you would think at some point, like, you know how like someone makes a great indie movie and then they offer them Jurassic Park and they're like, you know, his movie costs a million dollars, but he seems fantastic, which I'm all for. I've given people jobs like that. I've made all sorts of movies. I have never gotten a call to direct any movie. Now, not just like Marvel movies, like movies, like no one ever thinks I would accept a movie. No, they don't think you because they know you're good.
你知道的，你本以为在某个时候，就像别人拍了一部很棒的独立电影，然后别人就会邀请他去拍《侏罗纪公园》，他们会说：“你知道的，他的电影只花了一百万美元，但他看起来棒极了。”我对这种事绝对举双手赞成。我也给过这样的人工作机会。我拍过各种各样的电影。但我从来没有接到过任何导演大电影的电话。不仅仅是像漫威电影那样的，而是指那种大电影——根本没人觉得我会接受。不，他们不找你是因为他们知道你很优秀。
And they're like, they're like, Judd's got his own thing going. Like we're not going to bother him. We got this thing. You're the prettiest girl at the prom. Yeah, exactly. They're going to be like, but, but I will say, so sort of to that, one of the things that you do, I think maybe better than anybody's or I'd stack up against anybody is you really have a knack for finding new voices and new talent.
他们会觉得，贾德有他自己的节奏。我们就不去打扰他了。我们自己能搞定。你就像舞会上最漂亮的女孩。对，没错。他们会觉得，不过，话又说回来，关于这一点，你所做的事情中，有一件我觉得可能比任何人都做得好，或者说我愿意跟任何人一较高下，那就是你真的有一种发掘新声音和新天赋的诀窍。
And it's pretty remarkable how consistently you've done that for a long time. Not just new voices who like fit into what you do, but you actually find new people and you, you're very sort of flexible and you allow those voices to kind of grow on their own, which is really super awesome. Whether it's, I mean, I can name a million. I mean, you know, the entire cast of freaks and geeks to, you know, all the guys in, in whether it's super bad or 40, like all these consistently over the years. Is that something that you actively do?
而且很长一段时间以来，你在这方面做得如此稳定，这相当了不起。不仅仅是寻找那些刚好符合你风格的新声音，你是实实在在去寻找新人，而且你非常灵活，允许那些声音以他们自己的方式成长，这真的是超级棒。无论是……我的意思是，我可以举出上百万个例子。我的意思是，你知道的，从《怪胎与书呆子》的整个演员阵容，到……你知道的，无论是《超级坏》还是《四十岁的老处男》，所有这些人在这些年里一直如此。这是你主动在做的事情吗？
Or is it just something that you just kind of do? And it just happens like, you know, I was such a nerd growing up, you know, I just thought certain people were really funny and I would get very excited and I could only compare it to like, if you're a sports fan and you just go, I love, you know, Steve Garvey and you just can't get enough of him. I would watch like Jason Bateman in that show where he's mean to his, the guy dating his mom. What was that show, Jason?
还是说这只是你自然而然会做的事？事情就这么发生了，你知道的，我小时候就是个书呆子，你知道的，我就是觉得某些人真的很好笑，我会感到非常兴奋，我只能把它比作，如果你是个体育迷，你就会说，我爱，你知道的，史蒂夫·加维，你就是看不够他。我以前会看杰森·贝特曼演的那部剧，他在里面对他妈的约会对象很刻薄。那是什么剧来着，杰森？
It's your move. I would watch it. I mean, I would watch it. Your move. I'm not joking. And I would just go, that fucking kid will be so funny. So funny. It's happening on this show, but whatever that kid is doing.
《随你的便》。我以前会看。我是说，我真的会看。《随你的便》。我没开玩笑。我当时就会想，那个该死的小孩太搞笑了。太搞笑了。虽然这部剧现在正播着，但不管那个小孩在做什么……
And so then I would just like, in my head, track them like you would track Dwight Gooden, you know? And, you know, like with Amy Poehler, I watched her play Andy Richter's sister on Kona. And I didn't know who she was. I just thought, I think that's the funniest person. And then I did a pilot. I did all sorts of things. I was like, I think it's Amy.
所以我当时就会在脑子里追踪他们，就像你追踪德怀特·古登一样，你知道的？而且，你知道的，比如对阿米莉亚·波勒，我看着她扮演安迪·里奇特的姐姐。当时我根本不知道她是谁。我只是觉得，我觉得这是最搞笑的人。然后我拍了一个试播集。我做了各种各样的事。我就觉得，我觉得就是艾米。
Everything I did, I must have fucked up because nothing went. No pilot went, but like, that's how, how it works. And it doesn't matter what they're doing. I just have like a nerd's feeling of like, I want to see more of that person. Like I remember, I remember, so we first met, it was with Amy and you guys were doing North Holly with this pilot, with Judge Reinhold and Amy and Kevin Hart and Jason Siegel. So that was the cast. So we're all hanging out.
我做过的所有事情，我肯定都搞砸了，因为什么都没播成。没有一个试播集被选中，但事情就是这么运作的。不管他们在做什么，我心里就是有一种书呆子式的冲动，我想看那个人更多的表演。就像我记得，我记得，我们第一次见面是在艾米那里，你们当时在拍一部叫《北好莱坞》的试播集，演员有雷恩霍夫、艾米、凯文·哈特和杰森·席格尔。这就是演员阵容。所以我们当时都在一起混。
And then it's like, January Jones was hanging out at the time and there were just like so many. She was in it too. January was in it too. And we talked about it when Seth was on here and Brent Forrester was working with you on it or something. Remember we went over to his house one night in Malibu? Anyway, crazy.
然后就像，珍妮弗·琼斯当时也在那儿混，人真的是太多了。她也参演了。珍妮弗也参演了。当塞思来这儿的时候我们聊过这个，布伦特·福斯特当时在跟你一起弄这个还是什么的？还记得有一天晚上我们去了他在马里布的家吗？不管怎样，太疯狂了。
I have photos of this, by the way. I know. There are photos of like all of us together. This is in 2002, I think, 2001. This is January 2001. And it's all of us together. There are the largest joints you've ever seen, like comical, like Cheech and Chong. Someone must have done it as a joke, joints in the shots.
顺便说一句，我有这方面的照片。我知道。有我们所有人聚在一起的照片。这是2002年，我想，2001年。这是2001年1月。我们全都在一起。那里面有你见过的最大号的大麻烟，滑稽得就像契奇和钟。肯定有人把它当成恶作剧，照片里全是这种大麻烟。
I'd put them online, but there's so many like, you know, Bob Marley joints. But it's all legal now though. It's all legal now. But it is a funny group of people too, because it's like, you know, January Jones and Amy and Kevin Hart and you, and it's like, it's a fun set. It's so crazy. And Seth sent me one of those, a couple of those pictures and I was like, and I said to him, but I said that like, there's a show that you had, that you wrote, that you were
我本想把它们发到网上，但里面有太多，你知道的，鲍勃·马利式的大麻烟了。不过现在这一切都合法了。现在一切都合法了。不过这确实也是一群很有趣的人，因为就像，你知道的，珍妮弗·琼斯、艾米、凯文·哈特还有你，这片场一定很有趣。太疯狂了。塞思给我发过其中的一张，或者说好几张照片，然后我就……我对他说，但我是说，你曾有过一个节目，是你写的，你担任制作人，
producing and you had all this incredible talent on there. And like, if you went in today and said, I want to do a show with Seth and Amy and Jason and Kevin Hart and January, every network would be like, is a billion dollars enough? Can we give you two million? You know what I mean? Like you had this ability. And I guess, I guess like you say it is that thing. But even still, like even guys like Seth, like Seth talked about how when, you know,
里面汇聚了所有这些不可思议的天才。如果今天你走进办公室说，我想做个节目，由塞思、艾米、杰森、凯文·哈特和珍妮弗主演，每个电视网都会问：“十亿美元够吗？我们能给你两百万吗？”你知道我的意思吗？你当时就有这种能力。我想，我想就像你说的，确实有这种魔力。但即便如此，甚至像塞思这样的人——塞思曾谈到过，当……
there were freaks and geeks that you basically found him off a tape, right? Yeah. Vancouver. Yeah. He was just on a tape. That's so crazy. We wrote up a generic freak scene and a generic geek scene. And then we did open call auditions because I had this thought that anyone who would
拍《怪胎与书呆子》的时候，你基本上是通过一盘磁带发现了他的，对吧？对。温哥华。对。他当时就在磁带里。太疯狂了。我们写了一个常规的怪胎场景和一个常规的书呆子场景。然后我们举行了公开试播试镜，因为我当时有这样一个想法：任何适合在剧中担任主演的人，绝不会认为自己能找到一份演员的工作。那必须是那种觉得“根本没人会让我进娱乐圈”的人。
be right to star in the show would never think they could get a job as an actor or actress. It would have to be someone that is like, no one is going to let me be in show business. Yeah. Right. And so Seth, who I guess, you know, had was a little standup when he was like 14 years old, but he hadn't done anything. And we're just watching the tape and then suddenly there's Seth, right? And Seth is reading a scene that's all about how his dream is to grow pot underground and
对吧？所以塞思——我想，你知道的，他大约14岁时偶尔说过几次脱口秀，但除此之外他没做过任何事。我们当时正看着磁带，然后突然就出现了塞思，对吧？塞思当时在读一个场景，内容全部关于他的梦想是在地下种大麻，上面种玉米。
have a corn above it. And then there's a hole to the pot. And so if the cops come, you could just say, I'm just a corn farmer. And it was just him explaining his marijuana business. And it made us laugh so hard. We were just like, who is this person? And so we put him on the show and then he turned out to be very sweet and emotional. And the more work we did with him, the more we realized, oh, this gruff, funny guy is
玉米地里有个通往地下大麻地的洞。这样如果警察来了，你就可以说：“我只是个种玉米的农夫。”那段内容全是他向人解释他的大麻生意。我们当时笑得前仰后合。我们就在想：这人是谁？于是我们让他上了节目，结果他后来证明是个非常温柔、感性的人。我们跟他的合作越多，就越发意识到，哦，这个粗犷、搞笑的家伙，
just the tip of the iceberg. This is very fascinating, kind person. Isn't it amazing when you know what you want to do at that young of an age? It's almost like you are then no matter what destined to succeed. You already had a draft of super bad in his back pocket. Yeah. Wow. I was 18 years old at the time.
其实只是冰山一角。这是一个非常迷人、善良的人。当你那么年轻就知道自己想做什么时，难道不觉得这很神奇吗？这就好像你无论如何都注定会成功一样。你当时口袋里就已经揣着《超级坏》的剧本初稿了。对。哇。我当时才18岁。
So yeah, that's really all it is. And there was a moment where I was trying to cast big stars in an early movie. I was trying to get my first directing going. And every time I would try to do it, they would either say, no, or we're not available for two and a half years. And at some point I thought, oh, I just have to find someone who's not working. I need to find an unemployed person because everyone else is not available or doesn't want to work with me.
所以，是的，其实就是这么回事。当时曾有这样一个时刻，我在早期的电影中试图挑选大牌明星。我当时正努力开启我的导演处女作。每次我尝试这么做时，他们要么拒绝，要么说未来两年半都没档期。在某个时刻我想，哦，我只能找一个目前没工作的人。我得找个失业的人，因为其他所有人要么没档期，要么不想跟我合作。
So this sort of your affinity for scouting and finding these young upstarts. Is that how Leslie came onto your radar? And then you were like, well, I'll go one better. I'm going to try to put a ring on this. When we were doing The Cable Guy, that was very early in my career. Such a good movie. I love that movie. So I was totally in Ben World.
所以你这种对发掘和寻找年轻后起之秀的热情，莱斯利就是这样进入你的视线的吗？然后你就想，好吧，我得做得更好。我得想办法把她套牢。我们在拍《王牌特派员》的时候，那是我职业生涯的早期。太棒的一部电影了。我好喜欢那部电影。所以当时我完全沉浸在“本的世界”里。
Ben hired me on the Ben Stiller show, not really knowing I didn't know how to do anything. So I met Ben online at Elvis Costello Unplugged, and HBO had been asking him to do a sketch show and he just had an MTV show that was really brilliant, but not many people watched. And we met and started chatting about what would a modern sketch show be like. And then two weeks later we sold this show and we were the executive producers and HBO sold it to Fox. And now we've got a Fox show and neither of us have ever really made a professional show. We were in over our head.
本雇我在《本·斯蒂勒秀》里工作，当时其实并不知道我根本什么都不会。所以我是在埃尔维斯·科斯特洛不插电演唱会上通过网络认识本的，HBO 一直在要求他做一个小品秀，他当时刚在 MTV 做了一个非常棒的节目，但没多少人看。我们见了面，开始聊现代小品秀应该是什么样的。两周后我们就把这个节目卖了出去，我们成了执行制片人，HBO 把节目卖给了福克斯。现在我们有了一个福克斯的节目，而我们俩其实从来没真正制作过一档专业节目。我们当时完全是在硬着头皮上。
So HBO was just operating as the studio at that point then? They said they were going to put it on HBO and then one day they called us up and said, we sold it to Fox because they wanted to get in the producing game in some way. And so then the show, you know, we did 13 episodes and it was so much work and we got canceled suddenly. We were on at 7.30 on Sundays up against 60 minutes. It was a really weird place to put an edgy innovative sketch show, but I was in over my head.
所以 HBO 当时只是在扮演制作公司的角色喽？他们说他们打算在 HBO 上播放这个节目，然后有一天他们给我们打电话说，我们把它卖给福克斯了，因为他们想以某种方式涉足制片领域。于是这个节目，你知道的，我们拍了13集，工作量太大了，结果突然就被砍了。我们被安排在周日晚上7点半播出，跟《60分钟》打擂台。把一个锐意创新、剑走偏锋的小品秀放在那个时间段真的很奇怪，但我当时确实有点力不从心。
Ben knew exactly what he wanted to do and I learned everything from Ben. He really had a vision. And if you look at a lot of modern comedy and cinematic comedy and what Saturday Night Live has turned into, a lot of it is what Ben wanted to do back in 1992. He loved the idea of high production value cinematic comedy films. And obviously he was inspired by the Albert Brooks movies from Saturday Night Live and the Saturday Night Live parodies. And so then when we did the movie, it was a very similar situation, which was I was producing
本非常清楚自己想做什么，我从本那里学到了一切。他真的很有远见。如果你看看很多现代喜剧、电影喜剧以及《周六夜现场》后来的发展轨迹，很大一部分其实就是本在1992年时想做的事情。他非常喜欢那种高制作水准的电影化喜剧的想法。显然，他受到了《周六夜现场》中阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯电影以及《周六夜现场》恶搞短片的启发。所以后来当我们拍那部电影时，情况非常相似，也就是说我是那部电影的制片人。
the movie. I had never been the full producer of a movie. Jim Carrey's in it. And we really didn't quite know what we were doing, which gave us the courage to make something super weird because we didn't know that they expect something more down the middle and Jim was really excited to blow up the perception of him as just this silly guy. So he wanted to go dark. And so we just tried to do it without watering it down in any way.
我以前从来没有独自担任过电影的完整制片人。金·凯瑞也在里面。我们当时其实并不太清楚自己在做什么，这反而给了我们勇气去拍一些超级古怪的东西，因为我们不知道观众期望的是那种中规中矩的东西，而且金非常兴奋能彻底打破大众对他那种单纯搞笑小丑的刻板印象。所以他想走暗黑路线。于是我们尝试在不作任何妥协、不进行任何删减的情况下完成了它。
And then we just worked with all the people that we loved. The most Jack Black was one of his first movies was Owen Wilson's second movie. You know, there were a lot of people populated and was Leslie a piece of casting or did you guys know her before? And then they had just come off a great show called Birdland that Walter Parks created with Scott Frank. And you know, she was doing like really well at that time. And then we also read everybody in town, every single person in town.
然后我们只是跟所有我们喜爱的人合作。杰克·布莱克演的这是他的第一部电影之一，这也是欧文·威尔逊的第二部电影。你知道的，里面有很多熟面孔，莱斯利是选角选中的，还是你们之前就认识她？他们当时刚拍完一部叫《博德兰》的很棒的剧，那是沃尔特·帕克斯和斯科特·弗兰克共同创作的。你知道的，她当时发展得非常好。而且当时我们还试镜了城里的所有人，城里的每一个人。
But you're also skipping a big piece in there, which was you had done Larry Sanders, right? That was kind of in between Ben Stiller's show and Cable Guy, is that right? Yeah. And after. And after Cable Guy. Yeah. Yeah. Right, right, right.
但你也漏掉了其中很重要的一块，那就是你当时做过《拉里·桑德斯秀》，对吧？那大概是在本·斯蒂勒的节目和《王牌特派员》之间，是这样吗？对。还有在那之后。还有在《王牌特派员》之后。对。对，对，对。
And again, like that was one of those like seminal. I felt like that really changed the whole sort of definition of what was funny. Yeah. I mean, it was almost like Gary saw like network or something and decided to do a satire of egomania. I think Gary was just fascinated by his own need to be successful and famous and have everyone like him. So it's almost like he created a character that had his worst qualities and then he tried
而且同样地，那也是具有开创性意义的作品之一。我觉得那真的彻底改变了人们对喜剧的定义。对。我的意思是，感觉就像加里看了《电视台风云》之类的作品，然后决定做一部讽刺狂妄自大的作品。我觉得加里当时只是对自己的那种强烈渴望着迷——渴望成功、渴望出名、渴望所有人都喜欢他。所以这几乎就像他创造了一个拥有他身上最糟糕品质的角色，然后他试图去羞辱这个角色。
to humiliate it. Yeah. But there was no winking on that show. You know, it was incredibly dry and there was broadness at times, but no one was trying to help the audience know that this line is funny. This moment is funny. It was there was a darkness to it in the same way the Cable Guy was as well, that I just think that that just changed things a little bit in the industry in a great way that things
但那部节目里没有任何刻意的讨好。你知道的，它极其冷幽默，有时也会有夸张的成分，但没有人试图去提醒观众，看呐，这句台词很好笑，这个时刻很好笑。它里面有一种暗黑的色调，就像《王牌特派员》里一样，我只是觉得这在很大程度上稍微改变了整个行业，以一种很棒的方式让喜剧空间变得不那么流于表面。
became a little bit less obvious in the comedic space. You almost could say it was more inspired by Hill Street Blues and that world of where television was going than what was happening in comedy. Obviously, we were all fans of everything Norman Lear did and James Brooks and people like that, Larry Gelbart, but Gary also must have been, there was a great movie called The Hospital. You ever see The Hospital, this Patty Chayesky movie starring George C. Scott and it was all about how a hospital really worked and that it was kind of terrifying and scary and
你甚至可以说，它更多是受到了《希尔街的蓝调》以及当时电视行业发展方向的启发，而不是受当时喜剧界现状的影响。显然，我们都是诺曼·雷尔、詹姆斯·布鲁克斯以及加里·盖尔伯特这样的人的作品的粉丝，但加里肯定也看过一部叫《医院风云》的伟大电影。你们看过帕蒂·查耶夫斯基编剧、乔治·C·斯科特主演的《医院风云》吗？那部电影讲的是医院实际是如何运作的，那种感觉有点让人毛骨悚然，
it was like the network of hospitals. But it was before Chayesky wrote network? I think it came out before network and I always thought St. Elsewhere must have been inspired a little bit by it. And I think that's the space he was in. It was a little bit more of that Bruce Paltrow and that generation of the MTM hour long people who did all those great shows. Was Gary as hard on you guys when you were making that show or on every, but I don't
而且它就像是一个医院版《电视台风云》。但这在查耶夫斯基写《电视台风云》之前吗？我想它比《电视台风云》上映得更早，我一直觉得《圣处处》多少应该受到了它的启发。我觉得这就是他当时所处的创作空间。它更接近布鲁斯·帕尔特罗以及那代制作所有那些优秀节目的 MTM 一小时剧集制作人。加里在你们制作那部剧的时候，对你们或者对每个人都那么严厉吗？但我的“严厉”不是指他混蛋，我是说，他像剧中的拉里·桑德斯一样严苛吗？因为我知道有很多事情就像你说的，我喜欢那个非常有趣的观点，即他当时是在凸显自己最糟糕的特质，然后为此惩罚自己。有那种情况吗？
mean hard in a dicky way, but just was he as demanding as Larry Sanders was in the show? Because I know there were a lot of things like you said, I love that such an interesting idea that he was kind of highlighting his worst attributes and then punishing himself for it. Was there that? I think it was way worse. Like way worse. Really?
我觉得还要糟糕得多。简直糟糕透顶。真的吗？因为……因为我们所有人都爱他，知道他是天才，但我们也知道这个节目从一开始的架构就是为了狠狠整垮他。因为在此之前从来没有人做过，你知道的，除了《纯真年代》（我忘了那是哪一年开播的）之外，当时几乎没有什么单镜头喜剧，确实没多少。所以人们根本不知道该怎么做。
Like, because like we all loved him and knew he was a genius, but we also knew that the show was set up in the worst way to bury him. Because no one had ever done, you know, there wasn't a lot of single camera comedy at that time other than the Wonder Years, I forgot what year that started, but there really wasn't much of it. So people didn't know how to do it. And you guys almost did a hybrid. There was almost this sort of the proscenium kind of multi-camera elements, at least on
而且你们几乎做了一种混合体。至少在这部剧里，有一种类似舞台镜框式的多机位元素。是的。而当你走到后台时，就全变成了单镜头和类似真实电影的风格，真的非常非常酷。元素实在太多了。就像你拍情景喜剧时，你知道的，你在周一读剧本。
the show. Yes. And then when you went backstage, then it's all single camera and kind of verite and was really, really cool. It was too many elements. Like when you do a sitcom, you know, you read it on Monday. And then you'd rehearse for like, you know, a few days and then you tape in front of an audience on Friday, maybe you pre-tape some of it.
然后彩排几天，周五在观众面前录制，也许你会提前录制一部分。
And so there's a logical structure. With this show, we would read it on Monday, usually toss a ton of it out Monday night. They'd rehearse Tuesday and Wednesday. And then Thursday and Friday, like a movie, they would shoot at 17 pages a day. Wow. And it didn't feel like a TV sitcom taping. It felt like a movie if instead of shooting four pages a day, you'd shot 17 pages. Wow.
所以它有一个合乎逻辑的结构。而对于这部剧，我们在周一读剧本，通常在周一晚上就会把一大堆内容直接扔掉。周二和周三进行彩排。然后周四和周五，就像拍电影一样，他们一天要拍17页剧本。哇。那感觉不像是情景喜剧的录制。感觉就像是在拍电影，只不过不是一天拍4页，而是拍了17页。哇。
No way. But the week was basically treated in the same schedule. Like a sitcom. Yeah. Wow. That's crazy. I never knew that. I didn't know that.
不会吧。但整个星期的日程安排基本上是按这个进度来的。就像情景喜剧一样。对。哇。太疯狂了。我以前真不知道。我真不知道。
Yeah. It made no sense. And then the other two things was that they would have to shoot an actual talk show Friday night. So you'd finish at like midnight with the show and then suddenly for the next two hours, you'd have like Sugar Ray Leonard and Ellen DeGeneres on shooting talk show segments for all these episodes. And then we're writing him monologues and we're doing pre-interviews with Carol Burnett.
对。这根本说不通。另外两件事是，他们必须在周五晚上录制一档真正的脱口秀节目。所以你大概在午夜时分结束剧集拍摄，然后紧接着在接下来的两个小时里，你得让雷·伦纳德、埃伦·德杰尼勒斯这样的人来为所有这些剧集录制脱口秀环节。然后我们还得给他写独白，还要跟卡罗尔·伯内特做前期采访。
And so for Gary, he just didn't have enough hours in the day to act it, write it and edit it. And as a result, I'm sure you guys have been there, when you go, this script isn't good. I have nothing in the tank. You don't know how to fix it without me. So I want to kill you. Right. Right.
所以对加里来说，他一天当中根本没有足够的时间来演戏、写剧本和剪辑。结果就是——我确信你们也经历过那种时刻——当你觉得：“这个剧本写得太烂了。我江郎才尽了。没有我，你们根本不知道怎么修改。”所以我想杀了你们。对。对。
I heard a great story when we were, Jeffrey Tambor, who played our dad, as you know, on Arrest Development. He told me this great story that in the last season of Larry Sanders, he was trying to get everybody together to buy, to get a thank you gift for Gary. And so he decided, or somebody did decide they were going to get him a car. And he says, so we go, I'm going to tell everybody, and he says, he goes to Rip Dorn's dressing room and he knocks on, and we address him that I had for two years, Sean, when we were over there on the Radford lot with ribs dressing room upstairs or any company knocks
我听过一个很棒的故事，当我们在……杰弗里·坦伯——正如你所知，他在《发展受阻》里扮演我们的爸爸。他跟我讲过这样一个了不起的故事：在《拉里·桑德斯秀》的最后一季，他试图把大家聚在一起，为加里买一份感谢礼物。于是他决定，或者说有人决定他们要送他一辆车。他说：“所以我们商量着，我要去告诉所有人。”然后他走到里普·托恩的化妆间敲门，我们在拉德福德片场那边的时候，肖恩，那个化妆间在楼上或者别的什么地方，里普的化妆间，然后有人敲门，里普开门了。
on the door and Rip answers the door. Yeah. And Jeffrey said, Hey, yeah. So we're thinking about getting Gary present for the end of the series. He goes, yeah. And he goes, and we're thinking of getting a car and Rip looks at him and goes, a car. And he goes, and he goes, fuck you and slams the door in his face. That kind of thing would happen all the time at the show.
杰弗里说：“嘿，对啊。我们在考虑为剧集杀青给加里买个礼物。”里普说：“是吗？”杰弗里说：“我们在考虑送辆车。”里普看着他说：“一辆车？”然后他说：“操你的。”接着当着他的面把门“砰”地关上了。这种事在片场时常发生。
The show was also very hair triggered because you had all these personalities who were brilliant, but also would snap a little bit, right? And so buddy of sorts, there was one day where Jeffrey and Rip have a scene together at the table and in the scene, Rip's character, Artie, you know, calls Hank a fucking idiot, right? And then afterwards, Jeffrey's very upset and he's just like, Rip, I really, I really don't think you should call my character a fucking idiot. My character is not a fucking idiot. He is disingenuous.
片场的气氛也总是剑拔弩张，因为你们有那么多才华横溢但又脾气火爆的个性演员，对吧？所以有一次，有那么一天，杰弗里和里普在桌子旁有一场对手戏，戏里里普扮演的角色阿蒂（你知道的）管汉克叫“他妈的白痴”，对吧？然后拍完后，杰弗里非常生气，他就说：“里普，我真的……我真的觉得你不该叫我的角色‘他妈的白痴’。我的角色不是个他妈的白痴。他只是虚伪。”
So this is Jeffrey talking to Rip. Not Hank talking to Artie. Yeah, no, it's Jeffrey talking to Rip. He's like, Rip's here. He's disingenuous. He's not a fucking idiot, and Rip's toward this looks at Jeffrey and goes, well, my character thinks your character is a fucking idiot, and so they get into this, you know, bite about it and then Rip storms off and one of the producers follows after him and he's
这是杰弗里在对里普说话。不是汉克在对阿蒂说话。对，不，这是杰弗里在对里普说话。他说：“里普，他只是虚伪。他不是个他妈的白痴。”里普听了这话，转过头看着杰弗里说：“好吧，我的角色觉得你的角色就是个他妈的白痴。”于是他们俩就因为这事吵了起来，然后里普气冲冲地摔门走了。其中一个制作人追了出去，里普边走边说：
like, you know, fuck this place, fuck this. I don't work here anymore. This is fucking bullshit. And then he goes into his dressing room, he goes, I'm getting the fuck out of here. And then he picks up the phone and he goes like, yes, can I speak to my agent Bob Gersh, please? Okay. Can you tell him Rip Torn calls?
“操这个地方，操这一切。我不干了。这他妈太扯了。”然后他走进自己的化妆间，说道：“老子要滚蛋了。”接着他拿起电话说：“喂，请帮我接我的经纪人鲍勃·格什，好吗？……好的。你能告诉他里普·托恩来过电话吗？”
And then he just walked back to the set. I left work. I left work. The documentary I did about Kari was one of the best documentaries I've ever seen in my entire life. Incredible. I wrote your email and I meant every word of it. It was just incredible.
然后他又溜溜达达回到了片场。我离开工作岗位了。我离开工作岗位了。我为加里拍的那部纪录片是我这辈子看过最棒的纪录片之一。不可思议。我给你发过邮件，里面的每一个字都是我的真心话。真的是太不可思议了。
I never knew that side of Gary. I knew he was brilliant and I knew he was funny and sweet, but I never knew all of that. Yeah. He was just a complicated person, and I did understand him. Even by the end, when I was making the documentary, I would find out aspects about his life that I didn't understand before. How do you decide where to point your time? There's so many things that you're great at, so many things you're asked to do, so many
我以前从不知道加里还有那一面。我知道他才华横溢，我知道他既幽默又温柔，但我从不知道那些。对。他只是个复杂的人，而我是懂他的。直到最后，当我制作那部纪录片时，我依然能发现他生前我所不了解的生命侧面。你是如何决定把时间花在什么地方的？你有那么多擅长的领域，有那么多别人求着你去做的事，有那么多你肯定也好奇想去尝试的事，而且你还有一个美满得令人难以置信的家庭。诀窍是什么？
things I'm sure you're curious about doing, and then you've got this incredible family too. What's the trick? Usually, something kind of bubbles up, and then you have to decide if you have the passion and the energy to hang with it for years. And so, for instance, I had talked to Pete Davidson about a movie for a long time. I gave him an idea for a movie that wasn't very good, and I sent him down a blind alley for a couple of years with a very silly idea, and then we started talking about doing something
通常，某种想法会在脑海里渐渐萌芽，然后你必须决定自己是否有足够的激情和精力去为它耗费好几年时间。所以，举个例子，我跟皮特·戴维森讨论过一部电影，谈了很长时间。我曾给他提供过一个电影创意，但其实不太好，我带着一个非常傻气的创意让他走了一段弯路，花了整整好几年，后来我们才开始谈论做点别的……
more serious about his family. And then we started writing it together. I had a sense, like, I think I should be in the writing of this. It's very complicated, and he's so honest. He'll give me everything, and his best friend Dave Cyrus wrote on it too, but I felt like my experience would help shape it and find the tone. And then there was just a day where I just thought, I think I have to direct this. I don't think anyone else would know how to follow through, and that's kind of it.
对他的家庭更上心。然后我们就开始一起写剧本。我有一种感觉，就是，我觉得我应该参与到这个剧本的创作中。这非常复杂，而且他太真诚了。他会把所有的东西都交给我，他最好的朋友戴夫·赛勒斯也参与了创作，但我感觉我的经历有助于塑造它并找到基调。然后有一天我突然觉得，我想我必须亲自执导这部电影。我觉得别人可能不知道该如何坚持到底，差不多就是这样。
Because it had a specific resonance for you in your own life? I think on some level, and this is so strange, for years I'd been trying to figure out what can I make a movie about that would be fresh for me and that people wouldn't expect me to write about, and I kept thinking of the word sacrifice. I was trying to think, what do I not write about? I write about immature people and selfish people. What's the opposite of that? Oh, it's people who sacrifice to help other people.
因为这在你的现实生活中引起了某种共鸣？我想在某种程度上——这真的很奇怪——多年来我一直在琢磨，我能拍一部什么题材的电影，既能让我觉得耳目一新，又是大家意想不到的，我脑子里一直盘旋着“牺牲”这个词。我一直在想，我不写什么题材？我写的是不成熟的人和自私的人。那与之相反的是什么？哦，是为了帮助别人而做出牺牲的人。
So that might be an interesting area. And I tried to write two or three things on the subject, didn't pull it off, and then when I was talking to Pete one day, and he was talking about his dad, and what it feels like to have a parent be willing to die for other people, to save other people, I realized, oh, I must have been mentally preparing for this for the last five years. Just on some unconscious level, I knew this was what I was going to write, and I'm not spiritual generally, but I do sometimes get a sense of, oh, everything that happened brought me to the moment to meet Pete to try to help figure this out with him, and with everything
所以这可能是一个有趣的领域。我试着围绕这个主题写了两三个故事，但都没写好。后来有一天，我和皮特聊天，他聊起了他的父亲，以及当一个父母愿意为他人去死、去拯救他人时，是一种什么样的感觉。那一刻我意识到，哦，我过去五年其实一直在精神上为这个做准备。在某种潜意识层面，我知道这就是我要写的东西。虽然我通常不信神，但我有时确实会有一种感觉，哦，发生的一切都是为了让我走到这一刻，去结识皮特，并试着和他一起把这个故事琢磨出来，还有所有……
I feel that, I think. But you do kind of have that sacrificial, somewhat philanthropic instinct with what it is that you do, in that you find these young voices, these people that wouldn't otherwise have access, and extend that to them. So you've kind of been doing it, but you haven't been making stories about it. So I'll bet that's what clicked for you. I think it's, I have my own sense of, and this is how I relate to Gary, is that life is really painful for most people, or at least a fair amount of the time.
我想我能体会到那种感觉。但你在做的事情中，确实也有那种牺牲精神，或者说某种慈善本能，你会去发掘那些年轻的声音、那些平时没有机会接触到这些的人，并把机会延伸给他们。所以你其实一直在做这件事，只是你没有把这些拍成故事。所以我敢打赌，这就是让你灵光一闪的地方。我觉得是这样的，我有一种感觉——这就是我与加里的共鸣所在——对大多数人来说，生活真的很痛苦，或者至少有相当长的一段时间是这样的。
And Gary was very interested in Buddhism, and the first idea of Buddhism is life is suffering, and then you soldier on, and try to make the best of it, and try to be a kind person, and evolve. Yeah, I remember Sean, you told me, you went to the Rolex store, and it was closed, and they were like, come back in an hour, and you waited. I wrote a poem about suffering. Yeah. And you went back an hour later.
加里对佛教非常感兴趣，佛教的第一观点就是“人生皆苦”，然后你得咬牙坚持，尽量把日子过好，努力做一个善良的人，不断进化。对，我记得肖恩，你跟我说过，你去了劳力士专卖店，结果店门关着，他们说：“一小时后再来吧，”然后你就真的等了。我还写过一首关于苦难的诗。对。然后你一个小时后又回去了。
You said, it's an hour all you need, or you guys want to take some more time at lunch, because I can come back maybe tomorrow. Yeah, and I came back, and it was closed. They lied. There were heroes coming all the shapes, and so. Wait, I want to ask something really quick, because almost everything you do, or everything you do, Jud, is so real, and human, and grounded, and I think the most important thing when it comes to comedy, relatable.
你说，一个小时就够了吗，还是你们想在午饭时多花点时间，因为我也许明天再来？对，我又回去了，结果还是关着的。他们撒谎了。英雄总是以各种面目出现，所以……等等，我有个问题想快点问，因为你做的几乎所有事情——或者说你做的所有事，贾德——都那么真实、有人情味、接地气，而且我认为喜剧最重要的一点，就是能引起共鸣。
And so, does that mean that you're not as big of a fan of like, big, silly, physical comedy, or you are, but you just don't focus your work on that, but you enjoy it? Or do you just like, yeah, it's not for me, because so many sitcoms are not real or grounded. They're all kind of in a fantasy world that a lot of times doesn't exist, but what about those big physical comedy actors and actresses that we know? For me, I love that also. I think it's, in a lot of ways, harder to do. Me and Adam are saying that we talk about this all the time, that when we were making
那么，这是否意味着你其实不太喜欢那种宏大、荒诞、形体夸张的喜剧？还是说你其实也喜欢，只是你的作品不以这个为主，但你很享受？还是说你觉得，好吧，这不适合我，因为很多情景喜剧并不真实，也不接地气？它们往往发生在一个很多时候并不存在的幻想世界里，但是那些我们熟知的形体喜剧大咖们呢？对我来说，我也喜欢那种风格。我觉得从很多方面来说，那更难做到。我和亚当经常讨论这件事，当我们拍摄……
funny people, Adam was like, everyone's going to want me to do more things like this, but they don't understand how hard it is to just make people piss their pants laughing. And we all know that when you look at something like Airplane, you realize it is a fucking miracle. When there's a movie like Young Frankenstein or Blazing Saddles or something, there's nothing harder to do a joke for joke, rip down the house, no weak sections, comedy. And I've worked on a few, I co-wrote, you don't mess with the Zohan with Spiegel and Sandler and walk hard and I produce some movies like that, like Popstar.
《滑稽人物》时，亚当就说：“每个人都希望我多拍点这种风格的东西，但他们根本不懂，仅仅是让人笑得尿裤子有多难。”我们都知道，当你看到像《空前绝后满天飞》这样的作品时，你会意识到这简直是个他妈的奇迹。当有一部电影像《新科学怪人》、《灼热的马鞍》或者类似的作品时，要做到包袱一个接一个、炸翻全场、没有弱项的喜剧，没有什么比这更难的了。我也参与过几部这样的作品，我和斯皮格尔、桑德勒共同编剧了《佐汉同谋》，参与了《抢劫坚果店》，我还监制了一些类似风格的电影，比如《流行巨星》。
And I love them, but usually, I'm trying to find the emotion. I think in my head, I always think, can you tear down the house and at some point in the movie, make someone cry and it's the same movie and it's all organic and credible and you get there and it's not bullshit. You didn't jump over some logic that it's organic. You connect with it. Yeah. That's my favorite thing to do.
我很喜欢这些电影，但通常情况下，我更倾向于寻找其中的情感。我觉得在我的脑海里，我总是在想：你能不能既炸翻全场，又在电影的某个时刻把人弄哭？而且它们是同一部电影，一切都自然而然、可信度高，当你达到那个效果时，绝不是在胡扯。你没有违背逻辑，一切都是顺理成章的。你能与之产生共鸣。对。这是我最喜欢做的事。
But also, I'll tell you, there's nothing funnier than Sandler pouring champagne on all of the older women's ladies hairdos. Yeah, or just the big broad laughs that you get from a feral or a Sasha or Melissa or, I mean, it is a real high wire act and it takes an enormous amount of acting talent to take those big swings and still not leave earth. It's so wacky that it's like, oh, I'm getting a headache. And when it works, it's your favorite thing in the world. And how rare is it that someone makes you laugh to the point where you're screaming?
不过我也得告诉你，没有什么比桑德勒把香槟倒在所有那些老太太的发型上更好笑了。对，或者从威尔、萨莎或梅利莎身上获得的那些极其宽泛的笑声——我的意思是，这真的是一场高空走钢丝般的表演，要做出那些夸张的动作却又不脱离现实，需要极其高超的演技。它有时太疯狂了，以至于让人觉得“哦，我都要头疼了”。但当它成功时，它就是你世上最挚爱的东西。能把人逗笑到尖叫的程度，这是多么罕见的事啊？
I remember there was a scene in Extras where it was so simple, just Ricky Gervais giving a homeless guy, maybe he gave a guy like 20 pounds or something and then he just didn't think the guy appreciated it enough and then slowly started talking to him about it and by the end he takes it back from him and it just for some reason made me laugh like really hard just how it was written or improvised and I started laughing really hard, like losing it in bed and at Fleabag, there was a moment where they all punched each other in the face in the opening episode of the second season. But it was real and it was emotional but they found a way to suddenly snap on each other
我记得《临时演员》里有一场戏，非常简单，就是里奇·热维斯给了一个无家可归的人钱，也许给了20英镑左右，然后他觉得对方表现得不够感激，于是慢慢开始跟对方唠叨这事，到了最后他竟然把钱从人家手里又要了回去。不知为什么，这段戏的剧本或者即兴发挥让我笑得极其厉害，我在床上笑得前俯后仰，简直快失控了。还有《伦敦生活》，在第二季的第一集开头，他们所有人互相扇耳光。
and one by one, every person punched another person in the table in the face and I thought that is the most difficult moment I've ever seen in a TV show. You're right. I think that that was one of the great things about that show. It's a great example because that show accomplished something and I think one of the reasons apart from it just being hysterically funny consistently, but for people who do this as your job, you understand what a high wire act it was that she did, like how many narrow targets she hit one after the other after the other on that show, it was pretty remarkable from my,
但那是真实的，是有情感的，他们找到了一个突然情绪爆发的方式，一个接一个，每个人都在餐桌前扇了另一个人耳光。当时我想，这是我在电视剧里见过最难驾驭的时刻。你说得对。我认为这是那部剧最棒的地方之一。这是一个绝佳的例子，因为那部剧达成了一些成就，除了它一直以来都极其搞笑之外，我认为对于以这个为职业的人来说，你懂的，她所做的是一场多么高难度的走钢丝表演，她在剧中接连不断地击中了多少个极其狭窄的目标，这相当了不起——至少从我的角度来看，当时我在想：“操，这绝对是高水平的博弈，一直在发生。”说实话，我当时被震撼到了。
at least from where I was sitting, I was like, fuck, this is high quality, you know, gamesmanship happening nonstop. It was, it was, I was blown away by it, frankly. Yeah, no, I mean, I, and I go back and forth, you know, sometimes you make something that's like heavier and then you think, I just want to do like boner jokes for a year or two. For a while I was producing things for Will Ferrell and Adam McKay and so I would direct a movie and then work with them as a producer on their movies and it was just such a wonderful rhythm to, you know, watch them do something like stepbrothers, just as a fan, you know,
真的，不瞒你说，我的心态一直在摇摆，你知道的，有时你拍了一部比较沉重的作品，然后你会想：“我接下来这一两年只想拍点下流的笑话。”有一段时间，我一直在为威尔·费瑞尔和亚当·麦凯制作项目，所以我通常会自己导演一部电影，然后作为制片人参与他们的电影，这种节奏真是太美妙了。作为一个粉丝，你知道的，看他们拍摄像《非亲兄弟》这样的作品，看他们是如何工作的，那种感觉……
to watch how they worked and, and it was, you know, it was like getting to watch the Marx Brothers, you know, just sit at the monitor and watch, you know, Rudd and Will and Corell and Keckner and Christina do a scene and I felt like no one even gets to see this. Like all the stuff that's not making in the movie is the best thing I've ever seen in, in my life. You know, there was a scene where, where Will gets punched by Paul Rudd and Anchorman 2 and the joke was, what is the reaction going to be to him getting hit this hard and take after take, Adam and Will would come up with new reactions and you know, so in one reaction,
就像是在看马克思兄弟一样。你知道的，就坐在监视器旁，看着保罗·路德、威尔、卡瑞尔、科克纳和克里斯蒂娜演一场戏，我觉得甚至没人能看到这些。所有那些没有剪进电影里的片段，都是我一生中见过最棒的东西。你知道的，有一场戏是保罗·路德在《王牌播音员2》里打了威尔一拳，这个笑料的精髓在于：当他挨了这么重的一拳后，会有什么反应？一遍又一遍，亚当和威尔想出了各种新的反应。所以其中一种反应是……
he got hit so hard, he started speaking another language and then in another one, you know, and in another one, he gets hit so hard that he regresses and he's like four years old and he's like, and he's just like acting like a little kid and I was watching them run through like every way you could react to a hard punch and I thought this is my dream. Like I feel like I only make movies so that I'm allowed to witness this as a fan. We're just watching somebody like Will be able to pull off each of those enormously different choices so believably and then beyond that actually making you laugh. It's just, he's just a remarkable actor.
他被打得太重了，开始说起了另一种语言；还有一次，你知道的；还有另一次，他被打得太重以至于开始退化，就像个四岁的孩子一样，嘴里念叨着，表现得像个小屁孩。看着他们把各种面对重拳的反应方式都演了一遍，当时我想：这就是我的梦想。我觉得我拍电影的唯一目的，就是为了能以粉丝的身份亲眼见证这一切。我们只是看着像威尔这样的人，能够把每一种如此巨大差异的选择都演得如此令人信服，而且除此之外，还能真正把你逗笑。他真的是一个了不起的演员。
Will and Adam have that thing of like, it's, and Will's got like a, there's like a danger there. Like you don't know what's coming next and I remember him telling me a story that he and McKay when they were working at SNL would call from the 17th floor, like on a Tuesday, they would call Lawrence, Lawrence's office and say, hey, you've got Joe Torrey on the line here. They just had Jeter on the show, so they call, so McKay calls, he goes, I've got Joe Torrey here for Lawrence.
威尔和亚当有一种特质，那就是——而且威尔身上有一种危险的气息。你永远不知道他接下来会抛出什么梗。我记得他跟我讲过一个故事，他和麦凯在《周六夜现场》工作时，会在周二从17楼打电话给劳伦斯的办公室，说：“嘿，这里有乔·托瑞在线。”他们之前节目刚请了吉特，所以麦凯就打电话说：“我这有乔·托瑞找劳伦斯。”
So like they get put through to Lawrence's office and from Lawrence's perspective, he's like, oh, Joe Torrey. So it's McKay basically doing like, hey, listen, I didn't like the way you had Jeter on the show on the last week and it didn't make us look good. And of course it doesn't sound like, but in Lawrence's defense, he's like, I can't hang up in case it is Joe Torrey and so they go through and so he and Will give them shit, right? And then they hang up.
于是他们的电话被转接到了劳伦斯的办公室。从劳伦斯的角度来看，他会想：“哦，是乔·托瑞。”所以基本上是麦凯在模仿：“嘿，听着，我不太喜欢你们上周让吉特上节目的方式，这让我们看起来很不好。”当然，听起来一点都不像，但在劳伦斯看来，他不敢挂断电话，万一真的是乔·托瑞呢？所以他们就聊下去了，威尔和劳伦斯聊得不可开交，对吧？然后他们挂了电话。
But this is what makes those guys so like kind of what you're describing. They're like, yeah, let's call them back. And they call back. They do it a second time, you know, and it's like, yeah, when you have people like that who are willing to, and when you get to work with stuff like that, it's pretty remarkable. I have to admit to you something that, so years ago, we were doing, we were just maybe just finishing the rest of the development and, and we had met before a couple of times and then I was like, we were going to have a lunch together.
但这就是为什么那些家伙会让你觉得——有点像你刚才描述的那样。他们会说：“走，我们再打回去。”然后他们真的又打了第二个电话，你知道的。当你有这样一群愿意这样做的人，并且当你能和这样的人一起工作时，感觉真的很非凡。我得向你坦白一件事，多年前，我们正在做——可能正处于筹备工作的收尾阶段，我们之前见过几次面，然后我说，我们要一起吃个午饭。
Do you remember this? We went to the Daily Grill. You probably don't remember, but in Santa Monica years ago. And we went and you're like, hey, we're doing all this great stuff. You should come and hang out. And I was such a young, I'm not that much different, but I was such an idiot. I'm still kind of an idiot. And I was like, I'm kind of busy and you're like, come on over and hang out.
你还记得吗？我们去了Daily Grill餐厅。你可能不记得了，那是多年前在圣莫尼卡的餐厅。我们去了之后，你说：“嘿，我们现在在搞这些很棒的东西，你应该来看看。”而我当时还是个涉世未深的年轻人——其实我现在也没好到哪去——我当时简直是个白痴。我到现在其实也还是个白痴。当时我说：“我挺忙的。”然后你说：“过来玩呗。”
And I was like, I don't know, Jen, I'm kind of busy. And I sort of was like that, right? So I go and you're like, I think you were like, okay, man, or don't, you know, and I don't give a shit if you come over and hang with me and Seth and stuff. So I did it. And then I walked out and I was like, I had also just made like a little bit of money and I had like my first expensive car and I was embarrassed because I thought you were cool.
结果我说：“我不知道啊，贾德，我挺忙的。”我当时大概就是这副德行，对吧？然后我去了，你大概说了句：“好吧，随你便，来不来都行，我和塞思他们玩得正高兴，你爱来不来。”于是我去了。等我走出来的时候，我心想——我当时刚好赚了一点小钱，买了我人生中第一辆豪车，结果我感到很尴尬，因为我觉得你很酷。
And I was like, fuck this. And so I went into the bathroom and I waited as long as I thought you would valet to get your car so that you wouldn't see me get it in my fancy car. What kind of car was it? It was a Mercedes. It was the first time I ever bought a Mercedes. And I was like, you know, whatever, I was, and I wasn't young. I was like 36 at the time.
我想：“操，这叫什么事。”于是我躲进了洗手间，我特意在里面多待了一会儿，估摸着你叫的代驾已经把你的车开过来了，这样你就不会看到我开着一辆豪车了。那是什么车？是一辆梅赛德斯。那是我第一次买奔驰。我就想，你知道的，管他呢，我当时其实也不年轻了。我当时大概36岁。
Like it wasn't like a 21 year old. Oh no, I did this after a 40 year old virgin. I leased a Porsche, you know, because I thought, well, this is what you do. You get the 911. This is why we've been working. And it was a stick and I was not good at driving it. And it only seemed to drive well and be fun if you were going 90 miles an hour on the freeway.
这可不是21岁的小伙子。哦不，我是在拍完《四十岁的老处男》之后才这样的。我租了一辆保时捷，你知道的，因为我觉得，好吧，这就是你该做的事。你得买辆911。这就是我们努力工作的意义。结果那是一辆手动挡的车，我根本不会开。而且它只有在高速公路上飙到每小时90英里时，才好像开得挺好、挺带劲。
And so every time I drove it on the freeway, I was terrified that I was going to die. And I thought, well, this really isn't any fun at all. And then I left it in my driveway for two years till the lease right now. Jason used to call those guys Johnny got a show. Every time you see somebody, remember Jason on the lot, somebody would go, look at Johnny got a show with his fancy car. Judd, I want to switch gears to family. How are you liking being able to share everything that you know and that you've learned to your
所以每次我在高速公路上开它，我都吓得要死，觉得自己随时会送命。然后我想，这其实一点意思都没有。于是我把它停在车道上足足两年，直到租赁期满。杰森以前管那些人叫“约翰尼有节目了”。每次你看到某个人——还记得杰森在片场时吗？总有人会指着说：“瞧瞧约翰尼，带着他的豪车来秀节目了。”贾德，我想把话题转到家庭上。你觉得把你所知道、所学到的一切分享给你的……
girls? Well, I don't know. Is Iris getting into it? Because Maude certainly is. And she was fantastic in the film. Is she listening to the helpful advice you can give? She's really fun for me to work with Maude. I mean, she's very similar to Leslie.
女孩们，这种感觉怎么样？嗯，我不知道。爱丽丝也开始涉足这一行了吗？因为莫德肯定是这样的。她在电影里表现得棒极了。她会听取你能给出的那些有用的建议吗？我和莫德合作起来非常开心。我的意思是，她非常像莱斯利。
She's super honest and real and fierce and funny at the same time. And then Iris was on that TV show we did for Netflix called Love and she played a spoiled child star and was really funny. So yeah, sometimes I wonder, you know, am I ruining them by never mentioning any other possible occupation other than this? It's not like we talk about dentistry at the house or the legal profession. Like, I mean, if she ever walked up to me and said, like, you know, dad, I'd really like to get into accounting.
她超级诚实、真实、坚强，而且骨子里透着幽默。后来爱丽丝参演了我们在网飞制作的那部叫《爱》的电视剧，她在里面演了一个被宠坏的童星，非常搞笑。所以，有时我也在想，你知道的，我是不是毁了她们？因为我从来没向她们提过除了这一行之外的其他任何职业可能。我们家可不聊牙科或者法律专业。我的意思是，如果有一天她走到我面前对我说：“爸，我其实很想去当个会计。”
I'd be like, where the fuck that come from? You know, it's fun. I feel like we all have fun and if you can do it and I always encourage them to write and learn how to direct and hopefully they'll do that. I mean, it's, you know, it's enjoyable. Are they listening now? Can they admit the fact that you've been crushing this for a long time and you might have something smart to say?
我大概会说：“操，你这想法是从哪儿冒出来的？”你知道的，这很有趣。我觉得我们都乐在其中。如果她们能做到这一点，我总是鼓励她们写作、学习如何当导演，希望她们能做到这一点。我的意思是，这真的挺让人享受的。她们现在在听吗？她们能承认你在这行已经混得风生水起很久、而且可能真的有些高见吗？
They never will to my face. But then, you know, like Maude had to do press for the King of Staten Island. So I could read interviews with her where she'll reluctantly say nice things about me. So that's, that's the only way I, you know, I guess she does love me because she, she told the, the Vulture at New York magazine. But we had a chance to co-mingle when you and Leslie were doing a change up when my kids were little and we were pulling them around the hotel and that was like super fun just to get to watch you guys work together and you guys are so funny.
她们当着我的面绝对不会承认的。不过你知道的，比如莫德为了宣传《史泰 Staten Island国王》必须去接受采访，所以我能在采访中看到她很不情愿地夸我。所以，这就是我——我想她大概确实爱我吧，因为她在《纽约客》杂志的Vulture专栏里这么说过。不过，当你在拍《四十岁的老处男》时，我们曾有机会和莱斯利一起合作，那时我的孩子们还很小，我们在酒店周围带着他们，那段经历超级有趣，能看着你们俩一起工作，你们俩真的太搞笑了。
Oh, I had so much fun with Leslie. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, Judd, listen, I, you know, whenever I, and this is the truth whenever I see, you know, I'm a comedy nerd like you are. I know. I've done the documentaries over and over. Thank you for that, by the way. And I, you know, when I get giddy whenever I see your name on something because I know
哦，我和莱斯利合作得太开心了。哦天哪。好吧，你知道的，贾德，听着，每当我——说实话，每当我看到——我也是像你一样的喜剧迷。我知道。你做过好多纪录片。顺便谢谢你。而且，每当我看到你的名字出现在某个项目上时，我都会兴奋得像个孩子，因为我知道……
it's going to be great and I get super excited. Like it's fucking Christmas. I'm like, oh my God, I can't wait. It says Judd Apatowan and I'm so excited. What are you excited about that's coming up next that you can talk about? Well, we're, we're, we're producing a movie for Billy Eichner that he wrote with Nick Solar. Oh yeah.
那肯定会是一部佳作，我会超级兴奋。就像过圣诞节一样。我会想：“哦天哪，我等不及了。”上面写着“贾德·阿帕图作品”，我太激动了。你对接下来即将推出的、能跟我们聊聊的作品有什么期待吗？嗯，我们在为比利·艾希纳监制一部电影，是他和尼克·斯托勒一起写的。哦，是的。
You turned me on to him first. I love Billy. Yeah. So we were right about to shoot that when everything shut down. We were all headed to Buffalo. So that'll get going when they allow us to get going. And then I'm starting a George Carlin documentary right now. And I felt like, well, with everything that's happening in the world, he's only been proven
你可是第一个把我介绍给他的人。我太喜欢比利了。对。所以我们本来正准备拍摄，结果疫情爆发，一切都停摆了。我们当时全员都要去布法罗了。所以等他们允许我们开工时，我们就会开机。然后我现在正着手制作一部关于乔治·卡林的纪录片。我觉得，结合当今世界发生的一切，事实证明他……
correct about everything. It's fucking crazy, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Mike Judge too, with the idiocracy. Yeah. He had him pretty much mapped out. Both those guys.
对一切事物的预测都完全正确。这他妈太疯狂了，不是吗？对。迈克·乔治的《蠢蛋进化论》也是。对。他基本上把一切都预言准了。这两个家伙都是。
And, and, but Carlin, stand up. There are so many bits of that you listen to now and you're like, was he like looking through a fucking portal? Like it's. Well, he had a, he had a pretty clear point of view, which is you're getting screwed. Yeah. And, and, and that was his thing. He's like, if you don't think you're getting screwed, you're not paying attention.
而且，卡林的单口喜剧里，有太多段子你现在听起来都会觉得：他当年是透过他妈的时光之门在看未来吗？就像是……嗯，他的观点非常明确，那就是：你们都被坑了。对。这就是他的核心理念。他说，如果你觉得自己没被坑，那你根本就没用心观察。
And there really was a philosophy that, you know, the masses are being sedated so rich people can steal all your money. And there was a great routine that goes around where he says, like, you have no rights. You only have the rights that they want you to think you have. And it's pretty incredible because at the time people thought he had lost it a little bit. People were like, wow, he's a crank and he's really dark and there's not even laughs anymore. This is too rough. And now we look at it and go, oh, it's, it may not even be dark enough, but he, he lived
而且确实有一种哲学，那就是：底层大众被安抚着，好让有钱人把你们的钱全偷走。他有一个非常棒的常规演出片段，大意是说：你们根本没有人权，你们只拥有他们想让你们觉得自己拥有的人权。这相当不可思议，因为在当时，人们觉得他有点疯了。大家都在说：“哇，他是个怪胎，他太黑暗了，甚至都不好笑了。这也太尖锐了。”而现在我们回过头来看，会觉得：哦，这可能还不够尖锐呢。不过他活了……
a long time and he lived hard. Yeah. Did he, was he a hard liver? I, you know, I think he certainly had his, his drug period and I think he had a fair amount of, you know, heart problems in his life. The thing that's come up already, which is kind of amazing is how many people have contacted me to say that he was really cool to them. And so I'll just get emails out of the blue from a comedian who'll say, I bumped into him
很长一段时间，而且生活过得很激进。对。他是个生活放纵的人吗？我懂的，我想他确实经历过吸毒的时期，而且他的一生中也有相当多的心脏问题。现在已经浮出水面、而且让人惊叹的一点是，有那么多联系我的人说，他当年对他们真的非常好。所以我会莫名其妙地收到一些喜剧演员发来的电子邮件，说：“当我还是个开放麦新人时，我偶遇了他。”
when I was an open miker. He took my number. He would call me to check how I was doing and would give me advice. Multiple people saying out of the blue, my phone would ring and George Carlin would go, how's the set going? Wow. Just like a, like a real giver to the comedy community and, and people keep telling me, oh, I interviewed him for this.
他记下了我的电话号码。他会打电话询问我的近况，还会给我提供建议。很多人都说，莫名其妙地，我的电话会响，然后乔治·卡林会在电话那头问：“最近演出怎么样？”哇。他简直就像是一个对喜剧界无私奉献的人，而且人们一直在告诉我，“哦，我曾为这个采访过他”。
How many people have said they interviewed him for their school paper or whatever? So many people have said, I have a tape, you know, Paul Reiser emailed me the other day. Like in 1972, my sister interviewed him for her school paper. He's like, I got the tape. I mean, it's a lot of that way. Yeah. So I'm excited. So you're just starting that now.
有多少人说过他们为了学校校报之类的事情采访过他？太多人这么说了。我有一段录音，保罗·雷瑟前几天还发邮件给我说，1972年他姐姐曾为学校校报采访过卡林。他说：“我有那段录音。”我的意思是，这种事很多。对，所以我很兴奋。所以你现在才刚开始制作？
So that's like a year away. Yeah. Cause I'm dying to see that. I want to learn about him. Yeah. Easy. Easy a year. Really cool.
那大概还要一年时间吧？对。因为我太渴望看到了。我想深入了解他。对。至少要一年。酷毙了。
Really cool. Jesus, Judd. I can't, I can't thank you enough for coming on here today, man. Yeah. Very nice. Pleasure. I'm a giant fan of all of you. I hope we get to do it together.
真是酷毙了。天哪，贾德。我真的——真的非常感谢你今天能来参加我们的节目，老兄。不客气。这是我的荣幸。我是你们所有人的超级粉丝。我希望我们能一起合作。
I hope we get to make some comedy together. Incredible. I hope we get to do it. It's about fucking time. It is about time. Enough of Pete Davidson already. Right? Enough of Pete.
我希望我们能一起创作一些喜剧。太棒了。我希望我们能成行。这他妈早该发生了。确实早该发生了。皮特·戴维森的戏份够了吧？对吧？皮特的戏份够多了。
Enough of Pete Davidson. He had his minute with you. Pete Davidson, Pete Holmes. Too many Pete's. Let's move on. Pete Holmes. That's right. Anyway, Judd, thank you.
皮特·戴维森的戏份够了。他在你这儿已经有镜头了。皮特·戴维森，皮特·霍姆斯。皮特太多了。我们换下一个。皮特·霍姆斯。没错。不管怎样，贾德，谢谢你。
We've taken up way too much of your time, dude. Such a pleasure. You're a, you're a giant and a, and a really great dude and super funny and, and we thank you for your time, man. Yeah. It was an honor. Yeah. Thank you very much.
我们占用了你太多时间了，老兄。非常荣幸。你是个巨擘，是个真正的大好人，超级搞笑，我们非常感谢你抽出时间，老兄。不胜荣幸。真的非常感谢。
Say hi to your ladies. I will be well. Thanks, John. That was, that was fun, huh? And one of you guys, we were talking about Judd recently and, and I was like, he, he, he, he, he's going to be on the show. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
代我向你的女士们问好。我会的，保重。谢谢，约翰。刚才那段——那段真有意思，对吧？刚才你们谁来着，我们最近在聊起贾德的时候，然后我说，他——他——他——他要上我们的节目了。哦，对。哦，对。
You had him cooking. Cause when I do my laugh inside, I go, he, he, he, to myself, my internal life. Okay. Huh. Yeah. He's masculine as your voice. Thank you, Sean. If you mean it.
你把他逗得直乐。因为我自己在心里笑的时候，我会发出“呵呵呵”的声音，这是我内心的声音。好吧。哈。对。他的声音像你一样充满阳刚之气。谢谢你，肖恩。如果你是认真的话。
Yeah. I really look up to that fellow. He, he's doing, he's doing a lot of what I've, what I've been trying to do. It's amazing how prolific he is. I mean, it's incredible. The length of his career, the quality of his stuff, the philanthropy, as I said, you know, with the way he goes about his work, it's really, it's really impressive. There's not a lot of people that work like him in that he kind of gathers a troupe, but
对。我真的很崇拜那家伙。他——他正在做很多我一直——我一直想做的事情。他产出的作品之多真是惊人。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。他的职业生涯长度、作品的质量、正如我所说的那种慈善精神，你知道的，他对待工作的方式，真的——真的让人印象深刻。没有多少人能像他那样工作，他会聚集起一个剧团，但是……
then it's not sort of like a closed door that people come in, people, people leave. But there's always sort of this caretaking thing. You get the sense that, that he covers it all with in a, in a, in a nurturing way that's pretty. It's pretty rad. Yeah. So you're saying you like the length and you also like the girth, like the width, how much of his career.
然后这又不是那种把人挡在门外的封闭圈子，人们会来也会走。但这里面总有一种关怀的氛围。你会感觉到，他以一种非常滋养的方式包容了一切，这真的很酷。这真的很酷。对。所以你是说你喜欢他的“长度”，你还喜欢他的“围度”，比如宽度，也就是他职业生涯的广度。
So you like the length and the girth. Sometimes the length is the best part. And then other times just the width of what he can do. It's thick. It's thick. He's exploding the talent. Yeah. Cause you've been really.
所以你喜欢长度和围度。有时候长度是最好的部分。而有时则是他所能做的事情的宽度。很厚实。很厚实。他的才华在井喷。对。因为你真的很……
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Metaphorically speaking. There's all compliments. Of course, dude. Of course. These are compliments.
对。对。当然是从隐喻的意义上讲。这些全都是赞美。当然啦，老兄。当然啦。这些全都是赞美。
All right. All right. I love you guys. I love you too. Bye. I love you guys too. Bye. Bye.
好了。好了。我爱你们。我也爱你们。再见。我也爱你们。再见。再见。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
smart. Less. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
smart. Less. Smart. 本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。